plus il sera guidé et le brussels dollar
à la barre de la moyenne
il employait 1,6 à la casse et c'est une
impression pour relever la gomera
sociale je notais oppression je dois la
haute vienne
[Musique]
ans
je me considère en fait ce pas comme un
artiste et comme un footballeur
simplement footballeur qui joue un peu
mieux que les autres
[Musique]
la flèche est le prix ce sont les
patrons qui en décident moi je ne sais
pas si je suis bien payé ou pas et si
vous demandez à maradona
il vous dira qu'il vaut beaucoup plus
que 14 milliards de livres
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la première fois lorsque j'ai pris on
m'a suspendu c'est très bien j'ai commis
une erreur jeudi sera le ventre la
deuxième fois je crois que c'est
profondément injuste totalement injuste
parce et l'éphédrine
ça ne fait rien
[Musique]
on
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme d'affaires aurait mieux cibler
j'aimerais voir
[Musique]
del poso
génial et j'ai michel
le galop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et à peyrilhac 6000 tinto nothing
compares à convard savez le kiné
marolles qui ne vieillit
[Musique]
alors comment l'aja pcf à papeete quoi
comment je m'occupe je fais l'amour j'ai
toujours la même envie
les gens qui m'ont engagé me font
confiance pour appliquer les principes
[Musique]
et